hey everybody it's Charlie so we got the
first game of Thrones big teaser trailer
and a lot of you had the same questions
so I wanted to make a video to
specifically address this / GF here I
think this is a pretty accurate
assessment of all the comments on that
video
50% of comments John statue looks older
or is it just me
30% other assorted fan theories 10% Arya
is a badass
5% where is bran in another 5% talking
about your favorite scene so I'll talk
about all these specific things
particularly what's going on with Jon
Snow and what I think is really going on
in why bran probably isn't in the teaser
at least physically because most of this
teaser trailer is meant to be visual
metaphors just paying reference to a lot
of the things that they're going to
address during the season not actual
scenes from the episodes but yes of
course there's probably going to be
scenes of them in the crypts at
Winterfell we're still doing the Song of
Ice and Fire book giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on the video so starting
with the big stuff first we'll start
with a Jon Snow statue questions there's
a couple things that I think are going
on with this because yes his statue does
look much older than actual Jon Snow
whereas Arion sonses statues look like
them right now the young versions of the
characters so overwhelmingly people were
taking this to mean that potentially Jon
Snow would live to an old age and that's
why his statue looks old because it
wouldn't be constructed till he was an
old man and Arya and Sansa would be
dying young thus their statues would be
made in the likeness that they have
right now but really what I think is
going on here is that the statues just
aren't that flattering they're just not
great statues made to look like them
like if you look at this magazine promo
that they released with Jon Snow on the
cover it's him in his costume from
season 8 but if you look at his face he
looks like he just went through the
ringer like he looks like he hasn't
slept in days it's just not a very
flattering picture of him this statue
looks like it's made to look a little
bit more like this picture like Jon Snow
after 10 days of not sleeping or
trimming his beard like the beard does
look a little bit more full on his face
but if you look at the costumes that the
statues are wearing they're made to look
exactly like the costumes that are
wearing in this teaser so this is just
meant to be them hallucinating their own
deaths like oh this is a sign that we
might die this season are we going to be
able to change our fate will we be able
to defeat the night king
then the winds of winter come and blow
the torch out and you get all that frost
blowing in the crypts but another really
good example of why they're just not
great at making statues that look like
the characters on Game of Thrones is Ned
Stark's statue
remember when Arya came back to
Winterfell on season seven episode 4 and
salsa went to look for her knowing that
she would be in the crypts at their
father's monument so while this scene
was going on a lot of people after the
episode were commenting that that is a
terrible statue of Ned Stark it doesn't
look anything like him what's the deal
why is this going on a lot of people
were wondering about the sword that it
was holding because it doesn't look
totally like ice like how come this
isn't the exact likeness that you would
expect it to be so the simple
explanation to that is that they just
didn't do a great job and a production
design of what this ended up looking
like it's just not a very flattering
likeness of Ned Stark and obviously he
wouldn't be holding ice because they
wouldn't keep that in the crypt even if
Tywin Lannister had not have melted it
down into widow's wail and earth keeper
because of what's going on right now
with the fight with the White Walkers
they would have given ice to the current
Lord or lady of Winterfell obviously
technically by the traditional rules of
succession bran has Winterfell he's the
next heir in line but then technically
because Jon Snow is the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen and Lyanna stark he's not
ahead of Sansa in the line of succession
so Winterfell would pass to her before
it would pass to him unless the other
lords of the north
felt like he had a stronger claim and
wanted him as leader even towards our
Martinez said the last couple of years
that the rules of succession within Game
of Thrones aren't quite as hard and fast
as you believe them like their only
rules until someone decides to break
them so what would probably end up
happening is is that if ice were still
around they would try to give it to Jon
Snow but because he already has long
claw he would pass it to someone else of
his choosing like I've already got one
we need to put this in the hands of
someone else that can use it during a
battle but just to clarify I don't think
that there's anything strange or
spoilery going on with the older
different weird look that Jon Snow's
statue has compared to Orion sonses but
if you really want to talk about
foreshadowing and visual metaphors I
think the real reason why brand isn't in
the cribs at least physically in this
teaser is that he can travel there in
his mind so he's seen everyone that's
ever entered the crypts going back to
the creation of Winterfell in from a
high perspective HBO
wanted to show the more human seeming
star children becoming a Wolfpack like
the lone wolf dies the pack survives
lyanna stark's wolf like the she-wolves
a Winterfell just being really fierce
drawing their swords to battle the night
king in the White Walkers in a physical
way like when all the frost is creeping
up on them like they wanted to hype an
actual battle like a physical battle
where you run up and dash them to pieces
with the Valyrian steel and dragonglass
they'll be fighting with and when bran
fights the night king or tries to it'll
be more of a full-blown wizard battle of
the mind which in the context of this
teaser trailer in the crypts just
wouldn't be quite as cinematic and it
could potentially be very spoilery and
they're really trying to give away as
little as possible like usually on
screen teasers with brand versus the
night King are just brands eyes glazing
over in cocking his head then the night
king elsewhere will [ __ ] his head and
stare directly into camera freaking
everyone out making us know that he sees
brand watching him through time and
space so if they were to put something
like that in the teaser that could
potentially be very spoilery because I
do think that bran is gonna be very
important part of the battle but the way
he fights in his role in the actual
battle will be very different from
people like Jon Snow and Arya and the
other regular people that'll be swinging
swords but I do want to acknowledge some
of the bigger fan theories that people
had they were well thought out even
though I don't believe some of them so
some people in the comments thought that
because bran wasn't physically in the
teaser he was actually the mist itself
thinking that somehow HBO was trying to
tease that he was the night King because
of some complicated time-travel
greensight mess-up so yes even though
bran can travel through time and we saw
because of young Hodor in the sort of
mess up where he was using his green
side and working Hodor in the present
day at the same time it caused this
really crazy feedback loop across time
and space
so bran could potentially do that same
thing to this human here who's possibly
a stark of Winterfell in mess with his
brain while the children are turning him
into the original night king but I think
that's taking it a little too far and
even then that wouldn't make brand the
actual night king like this northerner
here doesn't look anything like brand
he's a completely different person he
has red hair that would just make the
night King a little more messed up in
his head
Hodor style and I don't think that's
going on either he's displayed a very
clear intelligence even though we've
never
heard him speak and probably won't on
the series but the whole thing with the
creation of the White Walkers by the
children of the forest was what the
children were trying to do was turn the
first men against themselves like
imagine a small group of the children of
the forest trying to fight hordes upon
hordes of First Men there was no way
they were going to win a war of numbers
so their solution was to use the first
men's numbers against them this way they
created the night king so that he could
effectively zombify their population
against themselves hoping that they
would cannibalize the rest of the first
men but as you saw things went
completely off the rails and the White
Walkers just wanted to bring winter
everywhere and turn every living thing
into a white or another white Walker so
like I said just more practical
cinematic reasons for not actually
having brand in this teaser don't worry
like when we get the next big proper
trailer he'll probably be in it they'll
actually be some dialog from the
characters a lot of the voiceover that
we got from Ned Stark from Lyanna Stark
from Catelyn Stark that's all stuff
taken from earlier episodes the first
real big trailer will actually have new
dialogue with them speaking to each
other like we saw in that scene with
Daenerys John and Sansa but hopefully
that explains everything I know
everybody wonders if they're gonna do
another teaser trailer or trailer of
some sort during the Superbowl it's
totally possible it's only a couple
weeks away so we'll find out pretty soon
but at least by the middle or end of
February we'll get another big one
there'll be more promo videos that I'll
post soon just leave all your requests
in the comments below
congratulations gf you're the giveaway
winner for my last big game of Thrones
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here to re-watch my Game
of Thrones Season 8 teaser trailer video
and Easter eggs
and click here for all my other Game of
Thrones season 8 promo videos thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight